and now we're back from outer space
don't know what we were doing in outer
space but we were evidently there
[Music]
alright guys so in today's podcast
episode we are gonna be given a few
updates some exciting things some
upcoming thing this we are gonna be
talking about how we've changed again
just cuz we've changed by two
we've changed Purdue because a lot has
changed in the last four months since we
are very first podcast episode oh yeah
and then we're gonna be playing Obama
llama once again yeah and I think that
we're gonna like keep score this time
yes don't know what the stakes are
competitive the first piece of news is
yesterday was our five year anniversary
happy anniversary
five awesome years of marriage it seems
like we've been together a lot longer
than that oh we have been you're right
we haven't
hello we've been eight years together
yeah like yeah but years and then we've
known each other that is a long time uh
twelve thirteen years thirteen years
we've known each other who's eight plus
five that's correct that's thirteen
years we've known each other for 19
years haven't we no that would have
meant we met in 2000 oh yeah
[Laughter]
thirteen years no but then that would be
20 2006 2006
yeah just like I'm forgetting like what
years we did things in like when we
graduated college when we graduate high
school and stuff
I just don't think about it at all
anymore I guess I just have it like you
know I think this the numbers must not
be that important to me anymore
so can't remem
months no can't remember how old you are
no so I guess like remembering the years
we graduated would be a lot to ask you
know it's like how is that super
pertinent you know I am the age I am NOT
abroad it doesn't matter you know
in some ways my humor is still that of
an 11 year old boy is funny I can't
believe we didn't make any stool jokes
and I still owe my gosh
what the heck yes it's okay everyone
made up for it in the comments yeah my
gosh they did but for our five year
anniversary we went out for a nice
dinner out we watched some TV shows yeah
yeah we finished that up oh man I think
we'll leave a list below of our favorite
episodes now again don't watch them with
younger people around they're very much
like very grown-up content it's like
violent and yes it's maturing but it's
also interesting because you know we
were thinking about a five-year
anniversary and I was like only do
something special I did make Caitlin a
present you did really fun yeah so it's
it's like a little it says Caitlin and
Evan and our anniversary days date and
it looks like Scrabble Scrabble yeah we
know it's Bananagrams because for me
Graham's if we could play that on the
podcast and make it doable somehow and
podcast form I totally would it's so
impossible we could have we could hire a
commentator to do a running commentary
oh yeah so it's like a magnets out of
what hippo is it again it's a fancy
fancy redwood but that has a weird name
a funny name yeah but um well well I I
actually fell
we'll probably put that up on our social
channel very soon he surprised me with
it by the time you're listening to this
it'll probably be up already so you can
check that out but uh you know I was
thinking about how I wanted to spend our
anniversary day and I was like you know
what we're pretty close to our ideal day
right now you know we got a little bit
of work done we played some games and
stream that then we you know hung out
together and went for a long walk and
you know it was great to have a well
balanced day where we didn't feel
stressed and like you know getting
behind on anything and we also took time
for ourselves so it was just kind of
interesting that you know it's like it's
extra corny to say but it's like the
biggest present we've given ourselves is
the life that we want to have and we've
been crafting that over the past two
years there's a lot of hard work yeah
and I I know like like our parents are
and friends and family are like you need
more breaks for yourself but it's like
what we do is really fun yeah it's just
but but also we're gonna be getting into
the student but we've we've continued to
kind of craft things and until it is
more and more enjoyable and we really
have in making a lot of progress yeah
but all the other things that like I
want to touch on we still have more
interviews to get to I'm sorry Paul Paul
Jackman and Jimmy dress so that we
haven't played your interviews yet we're
gonna get to them this is we keep on
coming up with so many topics there's so
much to cover maybe we need to do
bi-weekly podcasts you know last week we
came out with a podcast three Evan MPM
gaming's and our main Channel video so
that's five videos in a week that's
that's kind of crazy
every day and we streamed that's a lot
of contents a lot yes that's why we're
not gonna do what I think we might have
mentioned evident Galen gaming a little
bit during the department
diversification we did yeah that was
like the main topic of last week but you
know you know it's it's still going
along really nicely and it it is seeming
like it's a sustainable thing for us to
continue to do you know we've done three
gaming videos these past two weeks which
probably won't be forever well probably
stabilized on to per week yeah but it's
been really a really fun journey and you
know getting those edits in from our
editors it's just like opening a little
Christmas presents so fun to stuff watch
what they've created for us it's so
great other news that I want to touch on
is how to YouTube delays
how when you say how to YouTube are you
you are talking about our series that
we've talked about I know that's
problems like we talked we brought it up
so long ago and then it's has been
silence where we bring stuff up you
brought it up on the podcast I think so
we we've had it in our heads for a while
just quick recap if you haven't heard
this yeah
we've been talking for a while about
somehow putting out some form of content
that is like how to make youtube videos
and grow your channel and monetize
everything and we've been through a lot
of iterations of what that looks like
where that's gonna be if it's gonna be a
video if it's gonna be a podcast if it
is a video where is it gonna live and
everything and how are we gonna get that
out there but it's still in the works
we're still moving on some parts of it
it's just we need to get ahead enough on
on everything else that we can put time
into it just in case it doesn't work out
yeah yeah but yeah just we probably
won't give another update on it until
it's like happening yes just know that
or still yeah just wanted bring it up
that we haven't given up on it it will
happen it will happen sometime
eventually kind of related to that we're
giving a talk about how we went full
time before I think the number we set
along bkbk I think what we said I think
it was around 80k that was the roundest
number yeah yeah we're so spring make is
coming up in a couple weeks
we actually if you've been thinking
about going and
you haven't pulled the trigger yet we
have a coupon link it's not a code but
it's like a link so we'll put that in
the show notes and in the description
then you can get $100 off but so it's
event it's an event coming up and this
is its its second year but this is the
first year that it is kind of in this
form where it's gonna be like you know
open to whoever wants to come and it's
like courses kind of like well it's
interesting because there's like talks
that people are giving and there's also
workshops like hands-on workshops so you
can learn welding you can learn
woodworking you can learn a whole bunch
of techniques so it's an interesting mix
of a whole bunch of classes all squished
together yeah and I think the
interesting interesting thing is in some
of the other conferences that we've gone
to a lot of people are giving talks all
at the same time but in this one
everyone goes to every talk well that's
what we heard from one person I cannot
confirm that oh yeah you're right
we heard that from one person I can't
confirm that either because I feel like
I never get to go to the talks really
yeah so really really fun so we're
excited about that that's coming up in
like two weeks
yeah yeah all right so the topic it's
it's about how we've changed but before
we get into looking back and like where
we're at now and reflecting on that I
want to tell you a story it's not that
impressive a story but like you know it
happened last week during the buffer
week we um and I think that that it's
kind of important that we kind of had
this experience during the buffer week
because we felt a little bit more
relaxed during the buffer week we felt
like we could take a little bit more
time in the things that we're doing
because normally we're just rushing from
one fire to the next fire and they're
fun fires I like fire but you know it's
like when when we're watching a show
with lunch we always have to as soon as
we're done eating we to stop the show
pretty much wherever it's at we don't
like finish it you know for going out to
eat we go out to eat really quick at
quicker places and then we get back to
work if we go for a walk we don't just
keep on talking so during this buffer
week when we had a little bit more like
when we felt like we had a little bit
more time we we went to Benihana because
that's a longer lunch and we just
started chatting there and I think the
question I asked you is if we could do
things again if we could go back to
college or go back five years or
whatever two years and we could start
YouTube again we could you know reformat
our life what would we change and what
would we do differently and what was
your answer my answer was basically I
mean of course you know starting it
earlier as always yeah starting their
starting dating earlier it would have
been nice my answer is basically doing
what we're doing
but I think it would also be fun to mix
in some more I don't really know what to
categorize it as but like lifestyle
lifestyle lifestyles life in general
yeah not like a vlog because I don't
write I don't know it's not really my
thing but like you know trying to cook
something together in the kitchen
overcooked in real life or like I've
mentioned this before but I just love
the like my boyfriend does my makeup
videos it's like kind of the dumb stuff
but like but the more videos i watch of
that I try not to absorb much but the
more videos i watch of like my boyfriend
doesn't makeup I'm starting to pick up
things and then I'm gonna be be good I
mean you're gonna be good I'm an artist
I can art your face but anyways like you
know it's basically a mixture of the
stuff we already do with some of the
stuff that I like to watch yeah but I
think that the most interesting thing
that we realized is that we're not far
off well what would you want to give
your answer I think that my answer was
was very similar I would want to do this
pretty much exact same thing I wish that
I had have started like like I might
have started more channels and I'm not
sure if it would have been a good idea
or a bad idea to have that many channels
but I might have started like an
katelyn tech channel you know I might
have started like and you know this
isn't that we've gone back and forth on
like should we have Evan Caitlin make
and then Evan and Caitlin life or
something like that I don't know it's
like where do you draw the line between
these different content types
but that's something we might cover
later or we'll just figure out later and
tell you guys what we figured out
because like I think one of the things
we've learned is is it's difficult and
not really dangerous but like I feel
like we don't a mislead you guys but if
we project too far out on things that we
might or might not do and then we don't
do them then it's it's like I feel like
we're going back on our word yeah you
know everything here is well right now
we were just talking about if we could
go back in time what would we do
differently
yeah that's not commitment no but then
we came back from Benihana and we just
kept on hanging out on the porch and
it's talking about like the future and
where we're at and we had some really
interesting conversations and I just
thought like we should just do a whole
podcast about everything we talked about
which is which is what this podcast
right here potentially looking into the
future some things that we realized is
we do want to do more things like you
know like you know doing a Bob Ross
tutorial which is actually coming up you
guys can know you guys can know you guys
won't share too much I mean you're tying
that into that I would categorize that
kind of in like the lifestyle slash more
art more art side of things yeah I
wanted to do yeah but like you know we
can we can move into these different
directions and like keep my words are
getting confused because like I have so
many things I want to say at the same
time I know you're all over the place
because like when you have these
conversations naturally between like the
two of us we kind of move through them
linearly in one leads to the other but
like when you try to summarize them they
all get mish-mashed into my head well I
think I think so this is where we got
with the conversation all right okay
after talking about what we would do if
we could go back in time you know we
realized that those are things that we
might want to have the OP
to do some time we might want to have
the option to do more lifestyle stuff or
more art stuff or more like tech and
gear type stuff in the future the same
way we you know a little bit ago we're
like you know it'd be nice to do games
and now we're doing games and I don't
know you know if those things will
happen or what you know if they do when
they'll happen but it was interesting
talking about it and that that got us on
onto the subject of you know with the
gaming we started that as a separate
channel because it totally makes sense
but with these other things you know are
they do we do we wait until Evan and
Caitlyn is at a point where we feel
safer and like testing the waters in
these different areas if we want to get
to that point how do we take baby steps
towards that and so one of those baby
steps was doing the Bob Ross tutorial a
year ago I think that video would have
totally flopped yeah and it still might
we don't know yet because this is not
we're still taking a gamble but it's
something that I've seen a handful of
people do on YouTube where they like try
to follow a Bob Ross tutorial and it's
always hilarious and we've done a couple
art esque projects now with like the
acrylic pours a spin art like the geode
resin art and so we're like okay those
were kind of a baby you know baby steps
towards this project that is slightly
more I mean it's one hundred percent
alright but it's it's still like us
trying to tackle a project yeah you know
in a way it's just an art project but I
think like we've we've slowly been
evolving to get to the point we're at
where we felt safe in taking that baby
step yeah and I think a lot of that is
due to the past four months yeah which
brings up a good segue towards thank you
did a really good job
thank you flexing on the past out there
I didn't know what I think but I think
that's a really interesting thing that
we can kind of cover here like very
concretely and in-depth because you know
looking forward it's very hazy but
looking backwards you know it's
something that we do a lot and we've
analyzed the last four months a lot
because the last four months
have been more turbulent any other time
in our YouTube is so turbulent I mean I
think that starting in December that's
when we started messing with things
right yeah and I guess if you want to
talk about turbulence as in like ups and
downs that even started probably earlier
like in October so that's when we
started having some pretty crazy ups Oh
was that with the resin yeah you're
right yeah okay so the last six months I
was gonna say the last four months but
the fort for has really been when we
started consciously doing things yeah
right um but yeah so I guess just to
fill you guys in on some of the crazy
ups and downs of our video channel
performance back in October we started
working with resin and we started
working with Lowe's and the house like
renovation projects and the resin
projects started doing really really
well like yeah I think aside from
collaborations they were some of our
best performing videos it started off
with resin and then we had the laundry
room and then more resin and laundry
room and it's home renovations and resin
projects yeah yeah and so the channel
the channel was doing really well and
then we were simultaneously getting
super burnt out because around that time
we're also doing like six to seven
videos a month yeah we were super burned
out so we're super burned out um and
then come December we were like you know
what it's the holidays let's not over
schedule over schedule ourselves let's
have fun and just experiment with some
different stuff and not put pressure on
ourselves to do these huge projects I
mean we still did we still ended up
doing I think like five videos in
December but some of them were easier
projects yeah that's when we did our
very first ENK tuesdays wait and the enk
tuesdays since we haven't mentioned that
here that was kind of our first little
experiment with doing more casual videos
and we were like
you know we posted on Twitter and on
Instagram to get people's thoughts on
like talk about the types of videos we
wanted to do there that were a little
bit more casual and not necessarily
project based and we wanted to get
people's thoughts on do we put those on
a second channel do we start it you know
like do we put those on our existing
second channel did we start a separate
channel or do we just label them
differently within our own channel
people so label them differently so that
was our first we did a handful of them
our first like step into trying non
project based videos but then also
around the same time our main project
videos like our Friday videos we also
started pushing those a little bit you
know we did the beard we did the holiday
special where we I decorated your beard
and we did that well and we felt like we
could kind of experiment with that
because it was a Christmas Christmas
special and I was like it was okay to be
silly but also even like the willit cook
can epoxy cook an egg yeah that was like
our science video yeah let's try a
science video video and you know we had
a lot of mixed results there some didn't
work some did just to keep going because
there's there's no more than in that
period we also tried a video about like
our podcast setup which was kind of a
gear video yeah a little bit and then we
also tried our Mario Kart battle video
which was light robotics and electronics
but not like hugely project-based yeah
and then looking after that robotic
video we kind of took a step back from
experimental videos we went back to our
like core videos for a little bit but I
think that in the eight videos we've
made since the robot build we've taken
some of the lessons we've learned from
that experimental phage phage it's like
a bacteriophage or something
oh yeah the yogurt okay yeah but we've
we've taken some of the lessons we
learned from that experimental phase and
we've wrapped them up into the last
eight videos and I think - very good
very good results
interestingly okay so so all the most of
the videos I listed did not do well some
did okay there were a few videos during
that time period that you know were more
project-based like our shed that one did
really well but most of the experimental
ones even like the thrift store
challenge we did with David at first
that one did pretty great it's picked up
steam now and is doing better now but a
lot of them in the moment didn't do
super well and so we were really
discouraged after you know the end of
January we were like we lost it yeah
we're like we were doing so well
in october/november especially with all
the resin and the laundry room stuff
the rezident home project and and then
we were like what happened like we I
mean we knew we were experimenting but
it was our views were a like a 20th a
tenth of what they were doing that crazy
woman Grande do the crazy month was
crazy you know it's it wasn't it's not
really fair to compare like a super
well-performing month against a super
not well performing yeah month but and
like it's a it's a seems kind of silly
they're like not be complaining but like
boo moaning our videos getting like
still decent views but I think that it's
something that everyone faces like it's
it's it's the relative performance that
like yeah makes us happier hurts us in a
way and I think that like no matter what
your size of YouTube channel I think
everyone feels that when you when you
take a hit to what your norm is it's
always painful yeah I think it was
especially painful because you know the
experimentation was something we were
really excited we were really excited
especially about project type but
partially about like the filming and
editing style too
like trying to be a little bit more
silly and letting ourselves go on kind
of silly tangents here and there nothing
too crazy and trying to make the videos
more fun and you know just move further
away we had already moved pretty far
away from instruction but you know kind
of push it a little bit farther in that
direction
I was laughing at my caps favourite tape
I thought that was a great video I'm
just laughing at the thumb milk goes
like her little tongue is like licking
the tape yeah it's the only way to like
see her it's her eyes and her tongue I
think that that's when were we pushed it
that's probably the farthest we've
pushed mmm the Christmas sweater and the
vlog and the beard yeah we pushed it we
pushed it a lot but yeah so it was after
after the Mario Kart one which um that
was one where we expected a lot of them
we didn't really expect them to do crazy
game but that was one that we expected
to perform decently just like those
electronics Arduino and like you know a
lot of people have been asking us to
like try electronics and stomachs yeah
and and it was like Mario Kart
videogames you know um so we thought
that one would perform a lot better than
I did and so after that I think that's
when we were like okay we need to
re-strategize really shift a little bit
I think though they're like I can even
draw some very specific lessons learned
from specific videos I think one thing
that we learned from the podcast table
that was one that probably did the worst
relative to our expectations because I
didn't really think that that was too
experimental I think that you had more
reservations right about it but I think
the podcast had one of the biggest
lessons we learned is don't mix like
this the scope or the purpose of the
video as much as we did with that I
think sometimes purposes can be mixed
and sometimes it's a lot harder and what
we mean by purposes is this video you
know a lot of times our videos have two
purposes it's to kind of show off the
the making of the project and you know
show how we're making this thing and you
can make it too and here are some tips
you might pick up or maybe this is
inspiration and it's kind of about about
the project yeah and the other purpose
to just be an entertaining piece of
content you know even if you have
absolutely zero interest in the project
or making in general yeah and I think
that those two things can work together
because like the the process of taking
raw materials and putting it together
putting them together into a finished
thing is I think relatively generally
enjoyed yeah by people it kind of tells
a full complete story because it's the
same way that people like seeing like
home makeovers on you know on on HGTV or
like like watching time lapses of art
yeah you know even if you're not gonna
do it it's just kind of interesting to
see that transformation so I think I
think that those who can kind of go
together but I think with the podcast
desk we instead of make mixing a project
and entertainment we were mixing like a
gear slash tech video with entertainment
and I think that gear slash tech videos
are interesting if if you're like
interesting a person who's really into
gear or if you are interested in that
specific gear it's like it's like a
review kind of yeah they don't mix as
well as building and stuff doesn't mix
as well because I think like in terms of
entertainment value and and there's
definitely people I mean I know
sometimes you know you'll watch a tech
video even if you're not really
interested in that thing but it's
probably somewhat for like inspiration
yeah somewhat you know but I I this is
my opinion but I feel like it's probably
more widely interesting to see like a
transformation of materials from like
beginning to end into a finished project
product than it is to hear someone talk
about camera you know what I mean very
true and so I feel like mixing the
entertainment with that didn't work as
well because the people who saw it and
were like oh I'm interested in like
podcast equipment or audio equipment or
video equipment I'll click on that there
was a bunch of us goofing off in that
video like playing with voice modulator
modulators and just like bantering back
and forth and if I was someone who just
wanted to hear about the gear I'd
probably get super annoyed yeah and if
you were there for the entertained
you get bored about the gear yeah you
get bored about the gear so it's like
leaving out of the holes
yeah or you might not click on it at all
because you're like oh this is video
about gear I'm not super interested yeah
but I think that was one that I do a lot
of like concrete conclusions from I
think that things that I pulled lots of
little things from is is kind of our our
vlog videos you know I think that
filming those vlog videos helped us get
even more comfortable with kind of
talking on the fly talking a little bit
longer about things and kind of slowing
down the pace of our videos
yeah I'm not cutting so much out not
cutting so much out yeah yeah I'm making
it a little bit more conversational yeah
yeah cuz we used to like I would cut out
every pause in a sentence yeah I would
totally like Philip DeFranco bad stuff
but also it's like you know like like
the pace of a lot of our older videos I
can't even believe that we fit entire
projects into four minutes yeah you know
it was like everything was so fast-paced
and there was no fat yeah or something
it's very efficient but I think when
you're doing instructional videos I
think efficiency is there already
because if someone's watching something
for the instruction of it they don't
want two minutes of you talking upfront
about why you're doing it whereas like
we can banter for a couple minutes at
the beginning of the video yeah now and
it's the story of the journey yeah I
mean we still do try to like keep
ourselves well but I think the main
purpose right now is we want the entire
video to fulfill its purpose which is
like entertainment so if you need some
of that backstory to appreciate
something later on then that's critical
like bits it's critical bits it's it's
critical bits not that bit right there
that's some critical bits but I think
that you know the the things that didn't
work helped us like avoid those mistakes
going forward well one thing parts one
thing that I think I realized
is so during that time period we also
experimented with the kind of style
shift but still on normal project videos
like one example is the shed and I think
that that one that one performed well
that was it was a good performing video
but we still kind of filmed it in the
slightly sillier style you know leaving
in a bit more of the banter in the
conversations and funny things yeah not
like not including everything like step
one yeah we cut out a lot of steps yeah
just because they weren't they weren't
necessary for the video and I think that
that kind of showed me we did the same
thing with like the Wonder Woman yeah
video where it was like still a normal a
normal project in terms of type of
project and scope so that the Solar
shunned the Wonder Woman bracers but we
added in that kind of silly or editing
and I think that that seemed to work
yeah another I think I realized is we
don't need to tell people next up we're
gonna sand then we're gonna glue then
we're gonna do this it's like you're
gonna see us do it so it makes more
sense to like add additional information
such as like I'm really nervous about
this because I'm worried this will
happen that's more important than saying
next we're gonna do this you know or or
tell some story or say like we really
need this because of X or Y or Z tell
the story and then just show yourself
doing it yeah because like even if you
are watching for inspiration and you
want to see how we use resin or see how
we design things or you know whatever
else inspiration you're getting from you
can get that just by watching us do the
things yeah you know the things we like
if we say like okay we're really nervous
about part about this part because if we
mess this up we have to start over
that's that's one it adds to like kind
of the entertainment you feel like
you're hanging out with us and doing the
projects too and like oh the stakes the
stakes are so high but also if you're
looking for practical tips and you
gonna do that project and then it's like
oh I know I need to be careful at this
part because yeah this is actually like
a make-or-break moment in the project
yeah you know yeah so I think so many
lessons learned from the past four
months but one of the biggest
conclusions that I kind of drew is you
know three and four months ago we were
going through an experimental phase we
did our channel did not suffer a little
bit we went through a little bit of a
dry spell or something you know it
wasn't that great but what came from it
was so so so valuable in the long term
like I'm so glad we did that yeah yeah
because you know just like I was talking
with the shed and the Wonder Woman
bracers well it kind of seemed to work
when we combined these styles we decided
to lean into that more and you know
still still film like project-based
videos you know typically like mostly
project-based videos but mix it like
keep keep pushing it with the style yeah
a little bit more and I think that that
what resulted from that is starting with
the spin art spinner our channel has
been going crazy once we like figure it
out a little bit about our new style and
our new formula and started filming in
this slightly different way I think
things just clicked for us like the two
parts of the channel that we wanted to
integrate finally clicked after those
experimental Asian videos and then
things have been much better for us not
only in terms of performance but in
terms of our happiness Caitlin likes
editing more we like filming more and
it's just everything is better I don't
know yeah and it's interesting cuz I
can't I can't put my finger on exactly
why the spin art video kicked it off you
know but every video since then has
outperformed our typical performance
like crazy like to the point where we're
like I don't even know what a typical
performance is anymore because the past
two months have just been insane
yeah I'm trying to think of like why the
spin art well I have some theories on
the spin art what's your theory so I
think that the spin art
hits a lot of specific things that that
are like not necessarily repeatable
using something every day in an
unconventional way kind of like a life
hack kind of kind of like a little bit
of a life hack like taking a fan and
destroying it and turning it into a spin
art machine that that has an element
going for it yeah to nostalgia that's
another huge thing that like makes
videos perform better so using a common
object in an unconventional way
nostalgia and then accessibility you
know we've had so many people actually
do these yeah
which is so cool it's really cool and I
think that that that makes it more
shareable like you know someone watches
it let's do this this weekend or like
let's do something like this with your
kids you know and that makes it more
shareable yeah that's true that's true
so I think that those are kind of three
of the big reasons that may not always
be repeatable but then on the other hand
over here I think that there's there's
kind of two other things that we have
going for it one we kind of do show
enough of how to do it
we don't like lists step one step two
step three but I think that we still did
break it down enough so that people
basically understood yeah and I think
another thing is we were filming it in
that more kind of like come along with
us on this journey this like hang out
with us and that more like entertaining
casual style where we're not trying too
hard to be like but we're also um I
don't know just really excited about it
genuinely to take this on yeah I mean I
think we're usually pretty genuinely
excited about our projects but but I see
what you mean in terms of like we didn't
try to cut out like every moment so that
it was non-stop excitement yeah or cut
out every moment so that the only parts
left were steps those are kind of like
too extreme you know yeah but it was it
was that like I think it was one of the
first videos where I felt like we had a
really good
balance between the two yeah and it's
just been kind of crazy ever since and
it I am 100% sure that it will slow down
oh yeah oh yeah well we'll have another
dry spell I'm sure yeah but it is very
encouraging I think I think one reason
um
one reason for the like the huge
difference between December and January
and then like you know February I guess
I don't even know what happened like
March and April so far yeah I think I
wonder if it's because you know during
the beginning of the transition phase
you're gonna have people that don't like
what you're doing they don't like the
change we had not a ton but a handful of
people comment like really like maybe
five or so people it's not it's not a
lot but still stick with you people that
commented like you know I liked it when
you guys would actually show the steps
or I feel like you guys are just goofing
off now you know and I miss the old
videos and there's there's a few people
that commented stuff like that so I'm
sure there's even more people that had
that sentiment and unsubscribed and you
know if you're putting out videos and
there's a portion of your audience that
is unsubscribing and/or not watching
that's gonna hurt you and I wonder if
this first couple months like weeded out
those people yeah that weren't
interested in that content and then once
we had and everyone who is coming in
like that type of yeah and everyone we
bring in like that type of content and
we actually saw a concrete shift in our
audience demographics like we are you
know most so most maker channels we've
talked to him we still consider
ourselves like generally a maker Channel
but most maker channels we've talked to
have about 95% male audience yeah in the
age range of like 25 to 40 it's kind of
the typical and ours wasn't it was not
quite that extreme we kind of
consistently had like 30 percent 25 to
30 percent women we dropped I think to
20 or 15 and at one point we did yeah we
did drop
so we're still we still had a slightly
more balanced audience but it was still
like mostly guys in the 25 to 40 range
and now of your Evans pulling it out so
we can oh I want to see how much has
changed because it changes so frequently
yeah okay so now we are at I think at
one point we were at 50/50 straight up
like male to female now we are at 57
male and are 58 around up 58% male and
42% female but for a maker Channel
that's kind of crazy like crazy it may
not seem that crazy from you know anyone
on the outside but like we've talked to
like all of our maker channel friends
that we've talked to it's 95 plus
percent guys yeah and then we've also
shifted to a slightly younger audience
so now most of our audience is in 18 to
24 range instead of the 25 to 34 range
and I mean we still have a decent amount
in the 25 to 34 but we also have it like
we're in the 35 plus and the 17 and
under section like we're about equal
which is like we've never had that many
young kids watching but mostly 18 to 24
like that's a big ship so we we can see
in our analytics that there has been a
shift in our audience yeah and that
might be harder to see if your audience
was changing but they were still in the
same demographic as they were before of
it because YouTube gives you demographic
information we can actually see like oh
this is actually a lot of new people
like enough to shift our numbers very
significantly
yeah so I do think during that phase I
think one reason it started working more
later on you know part of it is we were
learning things and figuring stuff out
yeah but I think part of it is the
audience was actually changing yeah and
I think like a lesson there is if you do
want to change stuff you know and change
things because it's something you want
to do don't like chase a trend that you
just think will perform well because
like I feel like any change there's
gonna be some pain yeah change change so
that's sustainable for you but but I
think like the lesson is
you know if you're if you're making a
change for the right reason stick with
it and keep trying and don't give up
immediately because if we had given up
and we went through two months of just
really really bad performance yeah and
it was kind of discouraging but we knew
we wanted to keep moving in this
direction because it's what we found
that we enjoyed more and so we kept
pushing and now we're doing better than
we ever have before like we've had March
was our best month ever ever ever even
with like the traces in one month we
still didn't compare at all yeah yeah
even with last year the year of
collaborations this was still our best
performing month I like four times yeah
by an insane amount so I think like the
lesson is if you are someone who is
thinking about doing this and you want
to make a change don't let it discourage
you in the beginning yeah
yeah and kind of like where we're at
right now like self analyzing like cuz
though the past few days I've just been
like really content like everyday and
it's a really great feeling to have
because I mean in the past I've always
been pretty happy and we've always been
pretty happy but we've always also have
these bigger stresses on us and I think
one reason why I've been especially
content the past few days is because in
the moment I'm a lot less stressed and
I'm more happy because of the buffer
week that buffer week was so good I know
we talked about it last week I think but
knowing that we have that known that we
can do that and and and and like in the
moment feeling less time pressure it
makes enjoying the moment so much easier
and more possible but also long-term
seeing but four weeks in our future we
know that we can kind of regulate things
a little bit but also long-term I think
that after our talk at Benihana and in
the backyard about our future I feel a
lot more confident for I think not the
first time but I think that pretty much
this is the most confident I've ever
felt about our fee
direction yeah I think so too I think
it's just kind of it's like putting on a
shoe that fits really well like your
past shoes are too big or too clunky or
just like a little bit off and now
you're like oh this shoe this shoe feels
great he's great you know but you know
we've always generally felt like we're
on ish the right path but we've kept on
refining and we've kept on changing and
figuring out more about ourself and our
audience and YouTube and it just finally
feels like we're hitting a good stride
but also I think another reason that
I've kind of been realizing that is
making me happy is that sentence did not
make any English grammatical sense but
uh another thing that's making me really
happy is the fact that we can be
creative you know being creative and
like creating something whether it's
digital or physical or something has
always been an important part of my life
and I always wanted it to be an
important part of my life I always knew
that I wanted to be a maker in some way
and being able to do that I I don't
think I realized how important and
meaningful that was until I had a little
bit of breathing room yeah yeah I mean
to me it's it's also something that I've
always known that I wanted to be
creative in some form I didn't know that
it would be in a like maker way or in a
like video type of way it was mostly art
yeah but I mean like I think the videos
that you make are a work of art but um I
think another thing that we were talking
about the other day that we realized is
both of us have always wanted to share
what we make yeah well I think that's an
interesting thing is like I always knew
that I wanted to do creative stuff and
you listening you want to do creative
stuff but one thing I didn't realize is
that I've also always known that I
wanted to share the creative stuff I
make like I used to when I was like in
middle school I don't know if I should
say the website I don't think people can
look it up but I used to share
I like sci-fi and fantasy art online and
you know I I got some pretty good
recognition community of other 13 year
olds and then after that like when I got
my first apartment I started a blog
about it because I thought it was would
be fun to like share the things I was
like little like crafts and DIY projects
that you know it's hard to do stuff in
an apartment because you can't do
anything physic you know like
permanently to the space I was growing
up but the other stuff I could do and I
was sharing it even though no one was
looking at that we started a blog yeah
together when we bought our house oh but
but for me even earlier you had blogs I
had blogs I had I can say the website
because my websites so big and so
massive and I was creating the usernames
at that point in life where you create
dumb usernames for those on deviantART
and and I shared my art and stuff there
but I also started a blog that I can't
really say the name of because SEO is
still really good you can still find it
and it's kind of not embarrassing but
there's some like private details there
that we're trying to keep private about
our life and everything but uh yeah I
started a blog of my own in college and
I maintained it for years and it got
thousands and thousands of impressions a
day better than our blog that we started
really well you know it's like I started
getting Adsense revenue from it yeah but
I think like we always we we both knew
we want to do creative stuff but one
thing we didn't really think about until
like we were talking about it last night
that's one we're talking about this on
our watch
yep and we were like wait we the other
thing that we always have done and
wanted to do is share stuff so I just
think it's interesting that we ended up
in this position where we get to be
creative and share stuff and like the
sharing of its kind of equal part yeah
you know so anyways it's been kind of a
crazy journey over the past two years
but I think in particular the last four
months have been the craziest because
very formative in the four in those four
months we started a podcast we changed
our entire video style we
in gaming we have just grown and learned
so much in those past four months and
looking back across those two years it's
it's so interesting to kind of look at
those early days of just like pushing
through the mud and just working through
all of this for not as much reward but
like you know keeping that vision and
continuing to revise that vision until
it's at the point where we are just
really happy with how things are all
right guys
guess what time it is so today we're
gonna be playing Obama llama like we
mentioned before if you haven't tuned
into the last Obama llama
what it is is mmm there's there's - how
do you describe this I'll describe it so
so basically one person is reading or
saying a clue and the other person has
to guess the answer every answer is a
combination of some figure in pop
culture and an action they are doing
yeah so for example a very fat Star Wars
villain is trying to crack the hard
brown fruit of a palm tree Jabba the
Hutt cracks a coconut yep there you go
boom start with like a person or yeah
sorry the person a pop culture pop
culture figure and then move to what
they're doing there what there and so
someone give you a clue like the one
Evan just read some you can make up
clues I kind of like when we make up
clues okay okay so making up your own
clue does pose a challenge to both of
you but I also think that like you know
if this is a more even playing field
because all of the hints are pretty good
and thought-out
example we're starting we're starting
okay okay so the twist I want to put on
things is I want to keep track I want to
keep score so we can see who's really
the best llama to see who is the best
llama so I think that what we're gonna
do is we're gonna start a 15-second
timer every time we we ask like once you
read the clue you have 15 seconds to
answer and if you don't get it in the 15
seconds you don't get it count that
point okay
oh yeah and everything rhymes everything
rhymes yeah so like Obama llama
everything rhymes okay um are you ready
I'm ready
okay Tomb Raider is enjoying a green dip
that we also enjoy Laura Croft enjoys
the actress that plays human oh oh
guac guacamole Emily Foley I don't know
her name
it's very famous actress Oh Oh Angelina
Jolie oh damn a guacamole one a
guacamole thank you thank you for that
generous point okay no now it's my turn
to read to you that way cuz otherwise
like if we pass it back and forth I
might see a clue that was on the same
card or something yeah okay okay okay
okay
and once I'm done reading can you start
okay just push play to start it yes all
right so so you can't use any of that
drink use any of the words that are in
the answer it's like that's why I
couldn't say eating I had to say enjoy
okay so um a yellow cartoon flying
animal sniffs a brown stinky waste
object um Tweety Bird smells a turd yeah
no one's a bird like house need ascribe
a bird a flying animal right I got it
do you like my description I liked your
description of turret I guess it had
poop or something else yeah I think I
was trying to get like very descriptive
so I wouldn't say anything you know okay
cool
Frodo nobody gets in nobody gets them oh
is that that that's it I got the timer
Frodo nobody gets him nobody gets him
hobbit this emo isn't got a rhyme think
of Frodo Frodo hobbit is lonely no I'm a
hot Hobbit is perfect a pop culture
hobbit is not like the name of a culture
that actor that is Frodo is has a name
he has a name and no one no one gets him
emo no sad no lonely no no one gets him
not no one's hanging out with not if he
was I would say he's very sad and he has
dark hair that's in front of his face
no one gets him misunderstood yes
that's part of the answer do you know
his name Elijah Wood is this understand
yeah okay we're tied
okay all right the Dark Knight enjoys
this Canadian pop singers music okay
Heath Ledger I don't know a Canadian pop
singer is a huge ledger no Dark Knight
oh sorry
um oh the Batman oh is it just Batman
that's just Batman oh and it's a
Canadian music I think he's Canadian
well you live in the u.s. now but I
think he started he was from Canada
Batman listens to 50 cent I hope to find
him Bieber wait that doesn't rhyme that
man is a Bieber fan yeah yeah right
I think so Canadian singer/songwriter
okay fine
oh okay we're still tied see you just
don't know your pop culture enough
because I have all of the pups and the
cultures very cultured an upset feline
is consuming the thing she wears on her
head align us no it's not a lioness it's
not just a now
is a pop culture figure oh geez a an
upset feline very few disgruntled feline
angry cat ate her hat upset feline yes
oh you got the last part right made her
happy yeah but what's the first part
it's not angry cat Catwoman disgruntled
sad cat do you go peek at your first
attempt was just like sad sad sad
lioness like upset cat named her you
said angry cat I said that I should get
it I should get does like 90% of the way
90% of the way your brain went to angry
cat and didn't make the jump to wildly
successful fiction horror writer is
underwater and breathing through a mask
and but at the surface not really far
down Stephen King a snorkeling oh dang
you got so quick yes get like who was so
good okay a fictional um original Disney
character if you're gonna think of the
original Disney character he's a
fictional animal and he is in a a thing
that is often a blow up inflated castle
that you jump in bouncy bouncy
but he'll bouncy bouncy castle it's not
but it's castle isn't the word because I
used Dumbo's this is a male it's a male
original Disney think about like
original Disney Snow White know like
like if you think of Disney
face of Disney Walt Disney no character
I need an animal I said he was an animal
he's got large ears Lion King Dumbo he's
got large large ears Dumbo not the
original large ear Disney character like
Oh Mickey Mouse bouncy house bouncy
house
yeah bouncy house Mickey Mouse in a
bouncy house is that even a thing guys
comment below
that is dumber clue disney mouse by
Mickey Mouse in the bouncy house I think
it's so bad so bad okay ready I am it's
2 1 I'm winning oh my gosh oh my gosh oh
my gosh okay you ready and I started the
timer once you finish the clue yeah a
Jolly fat man that lives in the North
Pole is watching a scary movie about a
shark Santa Claus watching jaws yeah
what's good I gave you such a
fantastical clue that's good I'm the
best clue giver guy you winning is me
winning you know right I think so my
logic checks out the woman that has a
very popular um talk show who often
gives away cars is at a competition
where she needs to put the letters of a
word in a correct order
Oprah plays bingo
no no scramble letters in the correct
order
she needs to to tell someone what a word
is based on putting the letters in the
correct order see I think this is a
failure from the clue giver that's not
my fault okay Oprah don't eat Alaskan -
Oprah Winfrey what's a like word a slash
a letter competition that rhymes with
Oprah Winfrey moving with the free part
of Oprah Winfrey wheel of fortune
we'll ill fortune rhyme with Oprah
Winfrey no Winfrey win free free free
with the free yeah free so the
competition where she has to put letters
of a word in the correct order letters
of a word in the correct order
that's con competition in like school
spelling bee Oh see all things a game
show or something well I said
competition
I didn't say game show see Oprah Winfrey
Quincy telling me would you describe a
spelling bee without using the word
spell okay a talk show host who likes to
give away cars is at a school
competition where students compete to
always school or students see that that
would have been a good hint for me cuz
like doo doo adults but I think it's
like don't don't does it happen like it
camps where were I didn't want to limit
young kids compete to see who can put
words in the correct order this kind of
hard
maybe I'm just giving you too easy too
easy yeah I think I I might step it up
you know I'm gonna try to get you to
guess Sean beetle eats a sardine try
being eats a sardine see I know who Sean
Bean they're getting you to guess that
would have been very hard yes yeah I was
about to give you spider-man is a Barbie
fan but that would have been too easy
yeah see I think that was going for the
really easy one
no give me a give me like a medium okay
I'll give you a medium medium Justin
Bieber was good okay one of your
favorite I'm not sure if he's a director
or one of your favorite
I think I know is it Tim Burton oh okay
well if your favorite movie creators is
looking through something that covers
windows Tim Burton looks through a
curtain dang it
see I'm just too good at giving clues I
just know you too well I see the ones I
know you're gonna get okay okay okay
it's probably like four to one right now
damn yeah probably
you know Ben you're just gonna get more
crazy I'm gonna get more points okay I
have a good one this is the you know it
but this is gonna be like next level
difficulty point okay a giant green
superhero
it's very upset and pouting about it
Hulk is sulk yeah this is really weird
the wording is the Hulk is in a sulk see
that's so dumb a type a character in
friends is breaking into a house Monica
Monica is breaking is breaking a la coka
Monica oh I gotcha
I got you with that one 15 seconds is
fast okay mana is it Monica nope
okay is it the actress Courtney Cox
picking locks we'll see the thing is see
when you when you guess the characters
of the actor I would tell you like I'll
keep keep going you're just like shaking
your head in silence
I was panicking because I didn't have
the timer up and I had a count on my
fingers you know like there are
extenuating circumstances
that way we're not passing a main
character in ghostbusters and so many
other movies is eating a spicy Indian
dish
he also played himself in a movie we
were talking about recently
you got the dish right curry yeah who's
like the main guy in ghostbusters okay
no I know I know his name you know his
face no space this is what everyone is
you'd be like really quickly for
everyone who's listening you can't see
this but Kalyan set a timer for 14 hours
14 hours thank you for the generous okay
but yeah you're 15 seconds are up
I'm gonna get a lot of crap for this
crap okay I'll give you more clues oh I
know I know I know who he is I just
can't say his name you know his last
name rhymes with curry Murray yes Bill
Murray Ace Ventura actor owns a bird
okay Jim Carrey owns a canary yeah
mm-hmm like you've got like the owns uh
canary what you said like has a bird as
a pet
the rapper that's like hold up are you
lost me
hardy lost me hold up hey hold up that
hey please excuse me you hold to say
pressing been trusting that hey who
talks heard
okay okay um think so so neo likes to
preserve foliage from the outdoors and
dry it to save it for later he preserves
it in a book neo neo the doctor who
blaze neo could good thing I don't know
his name at all you know his name
I don't know Neos name do I saw some
Bill and Ted I do know his name hey you
you do know his name
everyone's Q yeah I know all the movie
she's from he's from like John wick he's
from a whole bunch of things and and
there's a meme about him being sad guy
who there's a meme about him being sad
putting on a bench yeah yeah
likes to so use the other part of the
clue okay
so if someone likes to preserve foliage
the other day they pass in the book so
what is that called
pressing paper in him dry dry flower
flower pressing he likes to press
flowers it's not flowers its foliage
press it's it's another part of a plant
that's not our just think of the most
normal word because I'm avoiding saying
it plant no he doesn't press plant
that's the other part of like a plant
that one might press aside from know
your presence flower pressed flower not
the flower it's not the roots don't say
bark don't say trunk or branch it's a
green part leaf yeah so he presses
leaves
yeah so blank likes to press leaves
press leaves leaves who presses leaves
people this guy don't video with flowers
and pretty things not leave
some people - leaves think about like
the green yeah I'm know I'm press leaves
you know when we did our project with
the Kennedy Reeves like the fresh leaves
press leaves okay you can't like get all
up in arms about the press leaves part
the part you couldn't get was skin
Harvey okay
a very famous cyclist who has battled
cancer for a long time is using a
paraphernalia that is associated with
marijuana Lance Armstrong uses smokes a
bong Oh
[Laughter]
misread this I thought it was a bong
yeah okay let's try this again
a famous cyclist hits a loud instrument
it's a gong yeah you know reputation for
using you got I got Hulk okay well I
think that this is this is my last
chance to get to three I think that we
should call it soon here the guy that
just has the best speaking voice and
people want him to narrate their lives
he played God in a movie once is
battling an unholy creature Morgan
Freeman battles a demon yeah yeah that's
a good place to end today's game show
segment you know what you know who even
cares about score I wonder if you know
where we're it's definitely at least
like six to three the score will be
displayed up above yeah in the video
version
cuz I was not fully counting we pretty
much tied probably thank you guys for
tuning in to today's oh no we need to do
the week so um my thing of the week is
something we've been slowly adding to
our life but it's reinforced kitchen
utensils that are made from a single
piece of silicone
so there's no seams they're really easy
to clean and there's a whole bunch of
different shapes and everything that are
you can get them in uh I'm not really
selling this too well but it's like okay
so you know you you know like you're
you're using a kitchen utensil and
there's often like a seam between the
like head of it and the handle yeah
usually like metal and plastic in the
seam and it's really hard to clean
sometimes works like all plastic or some
composite and then there's rubber bits
for grip and then the rubber bits start
peeling off and there's stuff to get
underneath them and it's just you know
part of it like that like the head of it
will be heat resistant like the handles
not so that's a handle yeah then it
melts so it's like these are all high
temperature silicone like 600 degrees
Fahrenheit the entire thing is like from
a single mold or no seam the really cool
part about it is is even cooler than
that if someone just had just like
injection molded silicone no floppy but
what they do is they like have like a
reinforced like inner part and then the
silicone one piece outside yeah so that
it's sanitary and easy to clean and that
it's reinforced you know so still usable
and I think that that's just like I
think that just real appeals to me from
like a design standpoint Plus like you
know we're always looking for ways to
streamline our life and even though like
cleaning an instrument that you cooked
with for five seconds versus you know 30
or 45 seconds or whatever it's not that
big of a difference but it's just like
optimizing I love optimizing and good
design and stuff so we just recently
like you know we started with the spoon
shala which is an amazing invention all
upon itself
spoon flows like a spatula mix with the
spoon yes so great but we've been
expanding into their entire line of
products and they just make good stuff
and put links to the ones we get yeah I
saw this something that more people need
to know about because like the people
need to know because like it's just as
expensive as a normal one but it's just
so much better
yeah and not just like it's crazy to me
yeah yeah so my thing of the week is the
current smarter every day
serious yeah that's all about like
different algorithm so he there's it's a
three part series he's done the first
two the first one was YouTube the second
one was Twitter and the next one is
Facebook but it's so fascinating and
like a lot of it you know it's about the
algorithm but it's also about how people
are gaming the algorithm and I'm it's
like secret battle that's going on
behind the scenes yeah it definitely
makes me not envy being in the position
of YouTube or Twitter or Facebook or any
of them because it's they're constantly
battling people trying to game the
system and it's about how people have
tried to game it and just like a huge
volume of gaming the system yeah that is
out there and like what they've had to
deal with
it's just crazy it's super fascinating
it's like how Twitter has to like I
forget the numbers I'm gonna be
butchering things but like let's say
that a million accounts are created I
think like maybe like a third of those
are accounts that are just robot so they
have a blog or something like that yeah
I forget the exact numbers I'm not sure
feels like a million today or a million
a week but I feel like millions of
tweets every day they get blocked yeah
because their robot tweets it's um it's
it's just like we're probably getting
the numbers wrong but it's crazy the
scope and scale of the problem is insane
it's insane and it's also interesting
because like there's no winning
yeah there's no winning for anyone
almost it's always just like a
compromise between it's like let's just
try to make it the best that we can
because there will be spam that gets
through and there will be legit content
that doesn't get through but if not none
of the countermeasures were being taken
then it'd be a lot worse
so there's we just constantly be spammed
with fake stuff yep yeah yeah but if
they went to extreme on the other end
then so many non fake account
would get accidentally fact yeah but
anyways it's super fascinating so we'll
link to that the smartereveryday
algorithm series yeah alright well hey
thank you so much for joining on this
week's podcast along pond pond yes it
was a long podcast and we'd really enjoy
if you left our pond casts some reviews
on whatever platform you use in or have
you shared our podcast with some friends
and family yeah don't call it don't call
it a pond gasps $20